ya hemos visto qué pasa al multiplicar
por 10 por ejemplo al multiplicar el
número 53 por 10 tenemos el efecto de
desplazar todos los dígitos un lugar
hacia la izquierda todo esto es un
repaso esto será 530 y podemos ver que
lo que estaba en el lugar de las decenas
se ha desplazado hacia la izquierda al
lugar de las centenas y lo que estaba en
el lugar de las unidades se ha
desplazado hacia la izquierda al lugar
de las decenas y hemos visto que si
dividimos entre 10 tenemos el efecto
contrario por ejemplo si tengo 120
dividido por 10 o puedo decir que esto
es lo mismo que 120 por un décimo que
obtenemos de resultado bueno en esta
situación todos los dígitos se
desplazarán un lugar hacia la derecha lo
que estaba en el lugar de las decenas se
desplazará hacia la derecha al lugar de
las unidades y lo que estaba en el lugar
de las centenas se desplazará hacia la
derecha al lugar de las decenas
así que esto será igual a 12 bueno todo
esto es un repaso pero en este vídeo
quiero extender esta idea pensando en
números que tengan valores posicionales
menores que uno o dicho otra manera
quiero que trabajemos con decimales
bueno para iniciar intentemos encontrar
el resultado de 3.0 15 x 10 pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrar el resultado
ok algo similar va a suceder todos los
dígitos se van a desplazar un lugar
hacia la izquierda primero tenemos al 3
en el lugar de las unidades al 0 en el
lugar de los décimos al 1 en el lugar de
los centésimos y al 5 en el lugar de los
milésimos ahora se desplazarán un lugar
hacia la izquierda el 3 se desplazará
hacia el lugar de las decenas se
desplazará hacia la izquierda
entonces en el lugar de las decenas
estará el 3 después este 0 que estaba en
el lugar de los décimos se desplazará al
lugar de las unidades el 0 estará justo
allí estará en el lugar de las unidades
no debemos olvidar el punto decimal y
ahora qué números deben de ir en el
lugar de los décimos de los centésimos y
del dos milésimos
bueno este uno se desplazará un lugar
hacia la izquierda es decir al lugar de
los décimos por su parte el 5 que estaba
en el lugar dos milésimos se desplazará
así la izquierda al lugar de los
centésimos y podemos poner un cero al
final en el lugar de los milésimas pero
como no afecta el valor de este número
podemos no ponerlo así que ya lo tienes
puedes ver que cada dígito se ha
desplazado un lugar hacia la izquierda
así que esto es igual a 30 punto 15 y
pondré el 0 aquí nada más para rellenar
el lugar perfecto ahora hagamos otro
ejemplo más pero a la inversa cuál es el
resultado de 67.5 dividido por 10 u otra
forma de pensar lo es multiplicarlo por
un décimo pausa el vídeo y piensa que es
igual
bueno ahora cada dígito se desplaza un
lugar hacia la derecha entonces el 6 se
moverá al lugar de las unidades el 7 se
moverá al lugar de los décimos y el 5 se
moverá al lugar de los centésimos así
que déjame escribirlo el 6 quedará en el
lugar las unidades después tenemos
nuestro punto decimal el 7 quedará en el
lugar de los décimos y el 5 queda en el
lugar del 2 centésimos y ya está
el resultado es 6.75